Hello, everybody. Welcome to a new episode of the
Center. I'm your host as always Ricardo Lobs. And
today I'm joined by Doctor Ioanna Malinovsky. She's assistant
professor of Philosophy at Adam Mitski Aic University in
Posen Poland. The subject of her research is a
broadly understood philosophy of science with particular emphasis on
philosophy of medicine, philosophy of neuroscience and philosophy of
psychology. She explores connections between these areas and questions
in bioethics, epistemology, ontology and methodology. Her current focus
is on the conceptualization and the use of ethno
racial categories in medicine. So, Johanna, welcome to the
show. It's a pleasure to everyone.
Thank you. Thank you for having me. It's a
great pleasure for me to be here.
OK, great. So let's start reps to introduce the
topic. Let me ask you what is cultural neuroscience
and what does it focus on exactly?
Mhm. So culture and neuroscience is a scientific program
that was introduced at the beginning of uh 20th
century by few researchers from the field field of
neuroscience. And the their um biggest concern was that
neuroscience usually treat culture to um in a, in
a too reductionist way. So it, it doesn't really
bother about it. They, they, that they treat human
beings and human brains in a sort of universal
stick way. And they started to insist that and
argue that um neuroscience should pay more attention to
the cultural factors uh that are involved into development
of human brain and human cognitive structures, as well
as the interaction between brain uh genes uh like
the, the, the, you know, epigenetic stuff and so
on and the environment of the individuals. So, mm
cultural neuroscience in, in is interested in those interactions
between those three major uh categories or entities. However,
I really believe that this term cultural neuroscience is
a bit um over it already because I want
to believe that most neuroscientists uh agree uh in,
in 2020 23 that our brains are plastic and
now that our genome is somehow plastic to a
point of course, and that we are uh bios,
social beings like bios, social animals. So we are
developing uh and, and uh while we are doing
so we are somehow embedding the cultural uh the
cultural factors and the, the, the cultural aspects of
our living and the, the uh cultural, socio, cultural
aspects of our environment. So the, the culture and
the society is a part of our cognitive um
of our cognitive uh structure itself. Um And just
to finish when the culture of the, the neuroscience
started to develop, there was this huge um the
biggest thing in neuroscience was probably the it was
probably the whole bunch of researchers uh interested in
evolutionary psychology and things like that. Right? So the
very, again, very universal perspective and very red reductionist
perspective uh when it comes to our minds and,
and our functioning like epistemic and cognitive functioning. While
mm at the moment, we already know that many
of those ideas. For example, the the thing that
there is some kind of no normal brain and
that each brain should look the same. Uh And
that the same structures should be in the same
place, have the same um should be um in
the same size and things like that. It is
uh it is some kind of idealization that is
totally wrong because our, our brains are developing through
all our lives and the way how they are
shaped depends on our experiences.
Mhm uh And so uh one of the topics
you've been interested in recently or in recent times
is uh race and ethno racial categories in medicine.
But in science more broadly, I guess. So what
do you think about the use of the category
of race in science more generally before we get
into medicine itself? Do you think it is scientific
at all to use it?
So this, this is actually the problem with the
category of race and ethnicity, but especially with the
category of race. Um So for me, it's uh
the, the great analogy is to think about this
this term, this notion of race as it was
some kind of mythical creature creature. So everyone knows
something about it, but no one actually knows what
it is. And this is what actually is happening
when people are talking about race and science, especially.
So, first of all, it is a highly contextual
category. So each community is actually understanding and interpreting
um it in their own way. Also each community
is actually trying to somehow set or negotiate their
racial hierarchies in their own way. So even if
there are no people of color in that community,
they will probably try to somehow develop. Uh Norac
Karch is based on other criteria than just skin
color. Uh TO be honest, uh racism itself uh
may be interpreted as a phenomena that started uh
as something that was not only um associated with
the skin color, but also uh was based on
criteria such as uh nationality or religion. Uh For
example, in the peninsula in like 15 century where
people who weren't, uh Catholics were uh yeah, were
sent off uh because they had a different religion
and they were treated differently. Also, there was this
uh at that time, the i the idea that
there might be some kind of pure blood and
the blood that isn't pure uh was developed and
it was also related to the religion at first.
So, um so as I said, first of all,
race means something else in different context in different
cultures, in different regions uh on our planet. And
this is the the first uh difficulty when we
talk about it because we all think that we
are talking about the same phenomena, but maybe and
the same classifications. And this is especially important for
science because usually, mm when we think about about
race, we have this strong intuition that there are
some kind of universal classic racial classifications, right? Like
uh people uh can be divided into blacks and
whites or yellows or um like this uh we
we think about this historical classifications that there are
like caucasians and, and negroids or something like that,
you know, uh while this is just one nara
one narration about class narration, classifications and in some
other like some places, there are other classifications. Another
thing is that when thinking about race, we have
so many stereotypes that are related to racist beliefs
in races that it's difficult to somehow abstract from
them. So even when research, like scientists are saying,
OK, race is just a social construct, there are
no biological human races. Uh BIO um biologists agrees
like population biologists agrees that there are no human
races. Um But maybe we will use some kind
of uh Norac classifications in, for example, in forensic
anthropology, but this is not a a biological race.
We try to somehow relate, for example, to ancestry.
But then what this ancestry means to people, especially
if it's somehow related to this very universal uh
classification that we all heard about like African Americans
and whites, for example, those are those two major
categories there, right? Or Asians as well. And um,
so if we, if we read a, a study
and people are writing about someone's ancestry and this,
um, this, this person or, or mm, those, those
reminds that are, that the researchers are trying to
identify, are assigned to African Americans or whites. So
what does it tell you even if they will
later say that this is not a biological uh
race, it is more of an ancestry and race
is just a social cultural project like a construct,
right? You will still probably have this feeling that
there is something biological there, right? And uh yeah,
and then finally, um we have this problem that
there are still some people who really believe in
some kind of, so say the scientifical um theories
or some kind of very politically motivated. Uh So
the scientifical, hm hypothesis and beliefs about races and
about some kind of differences between populations that are
called races um that are used but for political
reasons and for ideological reasons to somehow shape our
social reality, right? So uh to, to divide people
to, you know, we see there that, that kind
of um racist narration about different uh cultures about
the different um nations that they are worse than
others. Uh ESPECIALLY now when we have a war
in Ukraine uh which was strongly um related to
some kind of nationalist beliefs of presented uh in,
in Russia. At the same time, it was justified
by Russia that they are fighting nationalism, right? And
at the same time, there is like a huge
tension between Poland and Ukraine and all of those
countries that have their own historical um issues that
somehow rem that are somehow uh remaining racial or
racial uh Karch and racist narrations. So, um yeah,
there is a huge cause and a huge mess
and I really believe that um maybe there is
a good think to, to start like revising this
concept and you ask if I believe that the
race is a scientifical concept. So, so making, I
already said a lot but trying to somehow um
briefly present my perspective here, I would say that
definitely it does not because as long as it
is not strictly or somehow precisely defined in each
study, we really don't know what that means in
particular. Um CON without the context especially, but even
in a particular context, it is hard to uh
somehow infer what researchers or just uh normally people
think when they refer to race, what, what they
would like to refer to actually. Um And trying
to like fro from the philosophical perspective, I really
do believe like, I, I find the arguments uh
very persuasive the, the arguments that are saying that
maybe there are no races and no um like
the category of race as some kind of empty,
empty notion that is referring to many different phenomena.
At the same time, we could say that it
is very like we, we can understand it in
a very pluralist way, right? Uh But maybe it
would be more precise to talk about racialized individuals
and racialized groups because only by changing the the
language here to more process one to more contextual
one because we are rationalizing others or we are
racialized ourselves in some moment, right? And we can
change it. It's something that is a very dynamic
and not that static category. Race. OK. I am
that race or he is this race. But what
about the fact that people are changing their racial
identities? For example, what about the fact that they
are, they would be uh identified as having a
different race just by changing their uh their country
or something like that because in that country there
is a different a classification recognized by government, for
example. So yeah, II I would say that it
is not the scientifical category and um and probably
uh racialization is a much better concept.
Oh OK. So let's put a pin on that
racialization idea and also some of the other perhaps
consequences that it might have in the domain of
medicine. We'll come back to that later on. I
have a few other questions before we get to
that. But let me just ask you a follow
up to what you said because there are many
points that you mentioned there and many things that
I could touch on. But let me just say
that, uh, so on my show, at least since
2019, possibly 2020 I've had on the show, many
anthropologists, geneticists and biologists, uh, with whom I talked
about race, what were their ideas about race and
so on. And I mean, at least people that
come from those three disciplines, anthropology, genetics and anthropology,
genetics and biology that I think are the most,
the most well equipped to deal with these questions
and not a single one said that he, that
he or she fought that race at any sort
of scientific validity as a concept of it. So,
but, but uh uh uh on the other hand,
I guess that at least from uh let's say
sociological perspective, we have to take the category of
race as a social construct or less seriously because
it still has consequences in terms of social dynamics,
how people think about people from other racial groups
and me some medical consequences as we're going to
talk about later. Right? So, but basically I'm asking
you if, even though scientifically speaking, I guess that
very, very few people take race seriously. Um IN
terms of uh how uh people establish relationships in
our societies, how they think about other groups of
people and, and how certain groups of people are
treated and so on. We should take it seriously.
It has some sort of social reality to it.
Right.
Um So basically, yes, like making things short. Um
Yes, of course. I didn't want to say that
there is nothing like, um, a construct that is,
that is cultural, that can be ascribed to people
and just by doing so it can change, like,
shape their lives, for example, and shape their attitudes
to themselves and to others. Of course. um IT,
it has a lot of meaning to be a
racialized person. Like we have those arac identities. Uh
And I really believe that in a racist world,
each person has some kind of a racial identity,
of course, each grown up uh uh person because
as a Children, we, we don't think about that
kind of uh factors like that kind of problems.
Uh So ethno racial identities, as well as the
whole racist structure of our rewards. So uh sys
systemic racism and interpersonal racism. So all the interactions
with other people who have some kind of racist,
who probably have some kind of racist beliefs and
racist biases even if they don't want to because,
you know, uh we all believe in some kind
of stereotypes, for example, that, that, that govern our
uh way of thinking and, and behaviors, even if
we want to be 100% an anti racist and,
and very inclusive. Yet there are some kind of
um culturally acquired uh and embodied uh stereotypes and
beliefs that, that may somehow came up and affect
us even if we don't know, even if we
don't want to. Uh So when the category of
race is used in, for example, um sociology or
uh I don't know, like some kind of cultural
studies, it, it is meaningful and also it usually
refer to something that does exist that exists and
that really is important to, to investigate, uh especially
when it comes to cultural studies. It's very important
to learn how racism and racial hierarchies uh shape
human lives and all of that uh like the
uh the social structure, the, the social reality of
our, of our world. But still, when we think
about them as about some kind of universal and
objective categories, even if socially constructed, then we have
a problem because we are forgetting that cultures differ.
And this is the problem. I believe that because
we hear this very common uh in philosophy would
say like racial talk, um us, racial talk uh
that is based on us ethno racial classification and
their uh social situ situation, social context and economical
context and all the historical context and geographical context
that shaped the, the situation in us and how
race is interpreted there. Uh Then is it is
very easy for, for older people to somehow um
I don't know um somehow believe that this is
the, the way that like racial um divisions are
shaped generally and that's it. But no it's not
true. Like this is a very complex uh problem
that may uh differ different communities in a way
that they shaped their uh as I already said,
um how they shape their admiration uh Karch or
uh you know, the privileges uh that are given
to, to different populations and different uh diff different
members of the those populations. So the problem is
not the concept itself may, maybe the problem is
not the concept itself but the fact that we
think about it in a very, so I I
will probably um mm sorry, iii I will say
the same thing as I said before. So we
think about it in a very static and very
uh universal and, and so essentialist way and when
we think about essentialist category, but about the category
in a socialist way and that category itself is
somehow associated with essentialist beliefs about the race, then
it's very easy to, to, you know, to, to
skip from this point when we remember that we
are talking about very contextual and very processable and
very dynamic and diverse category that is uh sour
um uh category construct took place when we go
back to this uh essentialist belief that there are
some kind of biological races. And yeah, and the,
the way we talk about it about race, the,
the way how we describe it using certain words
is is problematic and this is where uh racialization
probably works better again because it is a, it
is not uh like an object, you know, a,
a verb, right?
No, I'm not very
familiar with English grammar. Sorry.
So I think it's a noun, right?
Yeah. Yeah. So, yeah. So, um it is something
that is happening, someone can do that. It's not,
you know, this um this thing that is stable,
that the thing, that thing that has some kind
of ideal uh shape or form that we can
you know, check if, if you have this and
this and that then OK, you, you are uh
white or black. OK. But, but
then le let's get into that already since you're
mentioning it again. So what does racialization mean exactly?
And how does would it differ exactly from the
concept of race?
So the concept of radicalization it it, of course,
it differs uh from philosopher to philosopher, from social
scientist to social scientist. So there are many different
definitions of radicalization. Um The way I understand it
is um is related to um very like evolutionary
uh interpretation of metaphysics I would say. So it
is it is uh related to um systems theory
and systems biology. And the the process all metaphysics
that usually comes with this evolutionary biological, like this
evolutionary metaphysics. And mhm And the fact that that
kind of ontology which is multileveled or multisystem or
that may be understood as somehow emergent. So uh
not in that strictly reductionist way. Hm from that
kind of perspective, radicalization is a process or um
many processes that produce or that lead to um
the belief that some person is uh representative of
some kind of entity uh of, of some kind
of group. Mm That is a major biological entity
or human lineage uh that was formed due to
reproductive isolation. Uh And that the membership in this
group is transmitted through some kind of biological uh
processes. So, um racialization, it's not about a question.
Are races real do races exist? But this this
about question, do we believe that they exist? And
do we believe that someone is uh has a
race? Mhm And this is the the uh the
most important difference between uh race and racialization from
my point of view, of course. So we don't
need to answer to this question anymore. Like am
I talking about only cultural construct or maybe political
construct? Because we also have that kind of conversations
uh discussions and philosophy of race, right? So some
people are saying this is only political construct and
others are saying this is maybe only social and
what are differences between political and social contract constructs
when it comes to the development of the idea
of race? So I don't need to answer to
this question because for me, what is important is
that some people identify with some construct, have those
identities and what is the uh characterization of those
identities? So here most important mo most important thing
is that it is processable. So I may have
some kind of ad no racial identity in time.
T but in different contexts, I may change it
or I may uh experience different aspects of racialization
in different contexts. For example, I may feel like
a person which is racialized uh as white when
I'm like a privileged white person when I am
in my country, uh like in Poland. Uh AND
when I help uh people who are so called
illegal migrants in Poland. So, so people who are
racialized as Muslims, for example, they may have even
light skin, but if they are racialized as Muslims,
they may face a lot of racism in Poland,
right? A lot of racist aggression uh and discrimination.
So in that particular context, I may feel like
a very privileged person. But if I just go
to Britain, for example, and I will move from
Poland to Britain or to France or to other
country, which is um more um which, which racialize
Eastern Europeans as that lower race historically. Uh Then
I may face some kind of some kind of
a no racial aggression and discrimination and I may
lose this white privilege. Uh This identity that makes
me uh more white. Uh W when I may
help someone else in my country who is racialized,
right? I know that it sounds a bit chaotic
but uh what I mean is we can change
those identities, but also we can this racial identity
and the, the fact that someone is somehow racialized,
it has some kind of state of racialization, I
would say uh it occurs on many different levels.
So you may be racialized on the level of
enviro environment differently than racialized on the level of
some kind of a sociopolitical mm Processes that, mm
I don't know, recognize your uh identity uh as
something else because I don't know, some law changed
and now you are uh you are not a
white but you are now a Latina, right? That
kind of changes happened in our cultures a lot
of time, many times. Sorry. Um You may also
feel differently than how people see you, right? So
it's also something else to be rationalized by others
and to have this admiration, identity and to rationalize
yourself. Uh AND in all of those uh context
um that kind of um the, the the organization
is something that is happening and is changing. So,
um I'm not sure if I explained it enough,
but um this is something that from my point
of view uh really differs this static category of
race and racialization. Hm.
Yeah. Yeah, I, I mean, I guess that uh
if we approach it on theologically, I guess that
uh race would be more of like a based
on a substance ontology. There is a more essentialist
category and racialization would be more based on uh
on a process on.
Yeah, that's right. Yeah. Yeah, you see, I, I
do research on it but, but you explained it
better than me. It's, it's probably because my English
and the fact that I was teaching all day,
all day long.
No, no, no, no worries about that. But le
let me ask you now. And do you think
that the category or the concept, the concept of
ethnicity fares any better scientifically speaking? Because, uh, I
mean, as we'd raise, I guess that when people
use the term ethnicity, not necessarily in science specifically,
but just in society, they might mean different things
in different contexts, right?
So ethnicity is another problematic term because again, people
are using it in as a very different notions.
So before you said that most genetics, like all
people who work on genetics, uh and biology generally
said that races, human races like biologically uh understood
they don't exist. OK. But still race and ethnicity
are categories that are used in biomedical research and
genetic research, genomic research, et cetera, right? And similarly
ethnicity and this is the funniest thing. So basically
the the my first understanding of ethnicity is that
it is more uh it is more cultural phenomena
because usually we talk about ethnicity um in relation
to language, culture, nationality, right? However, it it's not
always happening, especially when we look more closely to
to science. So OK, maybe in soc sociology or
something like that, it would be understood as strictly
social phenomena. But at the same time there was
this uh study in 2021 I suppose, or maybe
22 uh about how the usage of uh categories
such as race, ethnicity and ancestry changed or developed
in genetics. Um So in that study, it was
shown that researchers use ethnicity much more than race
at the moment. Mm For many reasons, for example,
um they want to avoid this very controversial uh
category of race. So they prefer to uh use
ethnicity instead of it or maybe they are from
UK. So they uh the term ray or ethnicity
is, is uh very often replaced with. Um uh
SO, so the term race is replaced with ethnicity
even if in their like uh caucus, right? So,
so they don't gather racial data, they just gather
and, and use eth ethnicity data. Um And uh
in such a situation, we have this, those re
those studies are in biomedicine, like in genetics, genomics
that still recognize uh hm population like uh differences
between populations on the basis of a, a category
of race and ethnicity or only ethnicity even. So,
then if ethnicity has something in common with some
kind of biological differences between people. And additionally, and
it was also um researched like it, it, I
even described this um such situations in one of
my papers. I if additionally, we apply uh th
that uh us racial talk to, to that to
those uh uh this term ethnicity. So if we
will understand ethnicity as some kind of proxy for
racial classifications. Then there is a huge mess here
because instead of trying to the biologist or the
centralized race, we are doing completely opposite. So we
biologist and centralize ethnicity. There is a lot of
papers where you can find information about um genetical
differences, like in some kind of um some kind
of gene gene polymorphisms, for example, uh between populations
and those populations are uh described uh with the
relation to us uh Arac classifications. So as African
Americans, white, um native Americans, uh Asians, etcetera. So
what then what that kind of ethnicity mean? Of
course, in other studies, it would be much more
precise because for example, they will use more demograph
understanding of ethnicity. So it will be uh closely
related to people, people's uh place of living or
something like that. And they would say not whites,
but for example, poles uh instead of whites. Mhm.
Um Yet still, what does it mean when it
comes to my genes? Right? That I, when, when
they call me just a poll we also have
now I I saw a discussion uh about a
new proposition for FDA at no racial classification in
USA uh or O MD at no racial classifications
like some changes and revisions and that they are
proposing and if you answer the questions uh uh
to in their mm in their new forms, then
you, for example, if you are white so called
white, then you can choose, for example, white pole
or uh I don't know white German. But if
you are pole and not white, there is no
category for you. But I know that there are
some poles that are not white like they have,
they don't have a white skin, right? So, yeah,
so this is another problem here. Uh Yeah. Yeah.
So perhaps let me ask you a somewhat broader
question because uh we've already seen here and also
again mentioning some other interviews that I've had over
the course of the last few years with geneticists,
anthropologists and biologists on the show and people can
go back and check them out. Some of them
have even raised on the title so you can,
you can get there easily. Um uh There are
so race and ethnicity are very messy concepts and
when people try to study, for example, differences between
human populations, sometimes they use those concepts, other times
they do not use them. But still do, do
you think that there might be some issues associated
with assuming differences between human populations when studying them?
I mean, expecting there to be uh differences between
human population.
I believe that there are human differences between human
populations. Um LIKE our populations are very variant, like
there is a huge variety between people, right? Um
And of course, it would be silly to say
that there are no genetical differences between people or
there are no I don't know, like other differences
between people. There are those differences but race and
ethnicity are a very shitty categories to, to be
used to, to study those differences. Um For all
of those reasons I talked about also like usually
race and ethnicity, like ethno racial data in, in,
in us are gathered um by uh information about
people's um self ID, ID, identification, right? So their
self identity, but what does self identity, what, what
it tells us about their genes? It is difficult
to say, right? And again, what the fact that
I live in Poland. Uh So I am appalled,
say about my genes, something probably. But we know
that our researchers uh our research, our studies, our
science may can be and should be much more
precise. And this is something that may sound funny.
But um like in this part, like in my
part of the world. So, so Eastern Europe, uh
people moved a lot because for example, because of
World War Two, right? And a part of my
family is uh from via, so a place in
uh contemporary Ukraine and they had to, most of
them were killed uh by nationalists and some of
them escaped to Poland, other parts from my family,
like other ancestors uh in my family could come
from some kind of um eee even more, more
from the west and from east. Sorry. So uh
my genetic, my, my DNA and my genome is
a bit mixed. So why it matters and why,
why I am talking about it first. Um Because
for example, when I was visiting a surgeon um
because I had some problems with my jaw. He
said that I have a mongoloid skull. Uh AND
it sounds a bit weird. Uh The the the
surgeon said, like look at my head scans, right?
RT G scans. Mm He, he, he said, OK,
you cannot spot it when you, when you see
your face, your skin. But when I see your
skull, yeah, it's definitely Mongoloid said. All right. Um
Yeah, and that's true. I have probably we have
some kind of Asian ancestors and sometimes it really
doesn't matter but sometimes it does. And for example,
if we, if we think about medicine and biomedical
research, it is very important. And uh and in
this context, I usually uh talk about uh one
situation from my life again, like especially from my
mother's life to be honest. Um So she had
some kind of um um some something grow on
her jaw again and her dentist uh sent her
to a surgeon. Uh THEY did some kind of
uh tests and said that probably it is a
cancer like a serious cancer. Uh BUT they have
to do a biopsy because they are not sure
they cannot recognize it. And she was like, afraid
she's dying for about three months. Uh Everyone was
saying we are not sure we cannot interpret your
uh results. Uh WE have some doubts but probably
this serious and she didn't know what's happening with
her. As long as one of her doctors sent
her uh medical data, health data to some kind
of international conference. And in Poland, we don't gather
and use erac categories when it comes to uh
health data. So there was no information about her,
the color of her skin. Uh AND as, as
fast as her skin was invisible to those people,
they only had her scans and the information like
the data, someone quickly said, OK, this is nothing,
this is nothing serious. This is just this uh
uh Asian thing that many Asians has, but it's,
it's not serious. Uh So, so she should, she
should be fine. So she had to lose her
skin like metaphorically and lose her race to be
di di diagnosed, right? And that kind of mistakes
in diagnosis may happen uh repeatedly when we believe
that race, especially someone's skin color and someone's identity
may be a good proxy uh for some kind
of genetical polymorphisms. Sorry in our like there is
no gene for race.
Yeah. Yeah. And, and that's the thing, right? Because
I was just going to ask you about that,
what in terms of health information, what are some
of the consequences that we having or we, I
mean, I'm saying that in particular countries it works
like that people have uh racialized health information and
what, what are some of the biggest consequences of
the the the negative consequences. Of course. So
again, this is a very problematic issue like a
very problematic uh question because from the one side,
there is a huge gap in knowledge about the
whole minorities, right? And in the history of science,
most research was done on white privilege, middle class
and young men uh because they studied in those
universities, universities where the research was done. Of course.
So for example, in neuroscience, until the beginning of
uh 21st century, hm most scans like uh F
MRI s and everything was done on, on, on
white uh middle class men around 2022 or something
like that. And it was, it was a huge
issue. So we started to gather a data about
other populations, about other cultures, like pe representatives from
other cultures uh about representatives of groups that were
um um were excluded from, from uh research before.
And this is great because we need to know
more about uh body uh woman bodies about um
bodies of people who experienced racism, uh bodies of
people who, who have totally different experiences than ours,
how it affects them, uh how different geographical um
um environment or economical environment changes and affects us.
Uh We, we need that knowledge, right? We also
need the knowledge about how we respond to different
psychological environments or how we should design cars for,
for people who are not a standard person, right?
And the standard person is always white. So um
in the mail, of course, so this is great
that we started to, to somehow worked with this
problem of a huge knowledge gap about other others,
generally. However, um when we are understanding those differences
through those categories of race and ethnicity, um again,
we are doing this mistake that we keep thinking
with essentialist and racist classes, I would say. Um
SO why it is important for uh uh to,
to talk about those issues uh when it comes
to health care and biomedical research, especially healthcare, because
you asked me about medical care, right? It's uh
it is because first um this is uh something
that is uh making racist beliefs stronger. So for
example, if we, even if we have a very
good uh intuition, like very good motivations, we want
to, we don't want to be color blind, right?
Uh And we want to um fully acknowledge that
we have uh patients that are from minorities and
that may have some kind of medical issues because
of that, for example, because of the effect of
um uh racist discrimination on their health. Um If
we just in fear that it is possible from
the color of their skin, then we are usually
um as uh thinking about it in a way
that is somehow racist just because we applied it
all this framework or connected with racial um discrimination
and it includes uh worse access to education and
living in poverty and maybe some totally racist stuff
like lower IQ um and things like that. But
why, like, maybe this is a person who is
twice as rich and uh you know, like wealthy
and economically privileged um than 20% of white people
in states or something like that, who of course
have their privilege as well. But we need to
learn how to uh recognize those aspects of our
identity that tell us something about the discrimination that
we could um experience. So when we try to
um research do research about the impact of racism
and racialization on, on people's health, we need to
be able to recognize on about which level of
racialization we are talking about. Are we talking about
lower access to health care in terms of um
like space that divides people from hospitals, like geographically
speaking, like very, very material thing or are we
talking about some kind of uh epigen uh historical
problems that the members of certain communities faced their,
their ancestors? Um So some kind of traumas could
be passed through generations or maybe we are talking
about the fact that uh someone uh won't get
some kind of, I don't know uh uh won't
get a scholarship or won't be published in the
scientific journal because he or she is from, I
don't know, Mongolia and people usually don't treat scientists
who are not from core countries as seriously as
others. So, Yeah, we, we just need to recognize
about what we are talking about, right? And when
we just use race and ethnicity, there are just
two broad concepts. They, they re relate to so
many different ways of discrimination, to so many different
experiences, to so many different things that, that no
one knows about what they are talking.
Right? And let, let me ask you a very
specific uh related question to medicine and health care
because I mean, by using categories like race and
ethnicity. But I guess even more so race and
medicine, one thing that people do is that they
study the prevalence of certain diseases across different races,
right? And uh together with that, usually I'm not,
I'm not saying that always, but usually comes the
assumption that because they find uh there, that there's
a difference in prevalence of certain diseases across races,
there must be a genetic basis to, to those
differences, right? And but isn't that also somewhat problematic?
Uh I, I don't know if you agree with
what I'm about to say or not, but I've
also talked with a few sociologists on the show.
And actually, for example, in the US, uh they
criticize some of the ways that people in medicine
deal with health information, racialized health information because uh
they say that uh perhaps there are some diseases
that have higher prevalence in uh black people. Uh
Black Americans, not because of their race or anything
genetic, but because, uh, I mean, if you look
at the socio-economic data, usually, uh, african-americans fare worse
in terms of their socio-economic status than, uh, whites
in America. And so some of that might be
explained not by genes or genetics, but by the,
by them being poor, their socio-economic status and all
of the things they are exposed to while poor
that perhaps other, uh, o, other groups in America
are not as exposed to as they are. And
I mean, I'm not saying with all of these
deaths, some diseases uh do not have any genetic
basis at all. Of course, some of them have.
But still, I mean, there are, there are these
complications that derived from the fact that uh there
are certain instances where we use racialized information in
medicine.
Yes. So yeah, I I was talking about it
actually, like there are some kind of differences that
uh are caused by social, cultural or economic and
environmental factors generally uh that may be spotted and
recognized as racial differences. But they um are there,
there was this uh great sentence that I really
loved uh uh And that was pretty popular during
COVID pandemic. Uh WHEN researchers try to criticize the
biolog organization of uh differences when it comes to
deaths uh of COVID between different communities. And they
use this uh a phrase that it's not a
matter of race, it is a matter of racism.
So, yeah, there are many differences between com like
many health differences in between communities and populations that
are caused by uh racism and social inequalities. However,
there are also some kind of differences between populations
that are caused by our genes. But yet, as
I said before, category of race and ethnicity are
not perfect categories to be used as a proxy
for those differences as well as our features such
as skin color, right? Like our skin color may
be important if we want to study how we
uh actually mm gain vitamin D, right? Because this
is or
perhaps for example, differences in uh in, in developing
skin cancer.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. So let's use a skin color
when we are researching something that is connected to
skin color, right? But even then the category of
race and ethnicity say us nothing. We just need
to use, you know, some kind of uh gradient
that is related to colors because I'm not sure
if uh if I'm right, but I would say
that many people who are white have a lighter
skin and darker skin, like my skin may get
very dark uh during summer. But I know some
people who just go outside and get burned in
like 10 seconds, right? And there probably is some
difference here as well that should be researched. So,
so yeah, if we, if we think that our
patient, for example, or or if we think that
in our study, something may be uh caused by
a difference in skin color, then focus on that.
If we think that some kind of differences between
populations or, or communities may be caused by socio
economic factors, then we should use some kind of
uh measures like frameworks that measure uh socioeconomical uh
mm differences and vulnerability, vulnerability. I'm sorry, I cannot
pronounce this word. Vulnerability. Yeah. Yeah. This one. So
if, if we think that some differences may be
caused by uh some kind of differences in health
literacy or diet, we should look at those but
not race in general because all whites don't eat
the same food and all blacks don't eat the
same food, right? So uh we just need to
be more precise about what we are researching. And
this is what I'm trying to say that in
some cases, a no racial identity may be very
important if we want to me, like if we
want to investigate, for example, how people experience stress
caused by their identity or how they, how does
the level of stress differs between them and between
people who self-identity differently? Like as a minority, for
example, when they face uh police uh policemen, a
police. Uh Yeah, just a police. Uh AND it
is um uh it is uh it was studied
by many researchers that usually people who are um
representatives of minorities. Of course, usually in those, in
those studies, it is written that black communities and
African Americans have a higher level of stress w
while facing police than whites. And this is totally
normal because of course they are discriminated and they
have to face this violence um on a day
or daily basis. But then, um, so, so then,
um their, their identity is important, it is relevant
in this particular context, but it's not relevant in
a, in a context of our genome. Right.
Right. A and so, I mean, basically these ideas
that you're putting on the table now about looking
at what's relevant in each particular case is what
perhaps a post racial kind of medicine would look
like. Right.
Um Maybe, yes, like we, we just need to
be, I, I love precision. Probably, maybe because uh
I'm a philosopher. Uh AND I wonder what concept
means? Maybe because I'm autistic and I love precision
even more. Uh But hm I think that in
science to make it functional and to, to, to
functionally communicate with other scientists, not to, not to
just create a huge mess like conceptual mess as
um as it is with, with the case of
race and ethnicity and their use in biomedical research,
we need to be precise but to do so,
we need to be aware that each of us
has a lot of beliefs that are sometimes even
unconscious. Uh A lot of ontological methodological beliefs that
we just acquired through our cultural training, education from
our scientific community even. And we usually don't question
them. But if we, if we just use some
kind of categories without any asking any questions, especially
if they are those such a controversial and, and
so powerful categories. Um Then it is, it is
um we need to, we need to ask those
questions, what are we, what kind of differences we
are looking for? Um What we are researching, what
do we want to say? Because even by like
the only by designing our research in one way
or another, uh we change our results and and
we we can affect it. So there is this
uh um this quote that what we put into
our, you know, research data, for example, it is
what we get in our results. So do we
need to put a racial data everywhere or those
categories everywhere. This is another question that from my
perspective is very important like in in USA uh
some institutions that finance uh biomedical research require scientists
to use gutter and use erac categories in their
studies. So they actually need to use race and
ethnicity as one uh of reference classes or subgroups
in their research, right? But it it is not
a neutral, it is somehow it may affect what
they are researching, how they are doing it and
what kind of results they are getting out of
the the research. So yeah, the the awareness of
like methodological and conceptual awareness in science is very
important from my point of view.
So let's change topics completely now, and getting into
the last part of our interview, let's talk about
a completely different topic that is human robot interaction
because you also have some interesting work on that.
I read a few papers of yours on that.
And uh I would like to ask you because
when it comes to human robot interaction, I mean,
there are many different aspects of it that we
could talk about here. But I would actually like
to ask you about empathy specifically. So uh this
empathy apply in this context of human robot interaction.
I mean, is it even possible for humans to
feel empathy for robots?
So yeah, I think so. Um THERE is uh
there are some kind of studies showing that those
uh areas of our brains are similarly activated when
we also report feeling empathy toward robots. As when
we report feeling empathy with people, uh people, people
feel that empathy like they, they can describe it
as similarly to a situation when we feel empathy
to some kind of cartoons. Uh WHEN we, while
we are watching movies or you know, when you
have uh plaques in your wall for electricity, electricity,
sometimes they look so sad or so happy like
when they looks like they have eyes and a
face. So we have, we are those weird animals
uh that have this tendency to anthropomorphize other beings
and other entities. Uh uh And if those entities
have some kind of features that makes it easier
for us to anthropomorphize them then, yeah, we easily
do so.
A a and, but what would be perhaps from
the perspective of philosophy of science? And I guess
that in this particular case, the specific areas of
philosophy of science that would apply here would be
something like philosophy of cognitive science, neuroscience, psychology, uh
disciplines like that. What are some of the explanations
out there for why we might feel empathy for
robots?
Ok. So, hm, this is a problem that I
investigated um as a result of my previous research
on other uh race effect uh and using category
of race in neuroscience because I had to write
something about robot be robots being uh a part
of the team where the P I asked me,
OK, you should do so. So, you know, you
don't have a job, you have to, you have
to uh take what they give you. So, so
yeah, uh I had to switch and after reading
a lot of papers about um uh human robot
interactions, I just spotted that in many cases they
refer to empathy. Um And as I already told
you, I love precision, but I saw that this
term, this notion empathy is used differently and understood
differently in almost every, every study. And that's OK.
We can agree that sometimes when some kind of
concepts uh even if they are, even if no
one knows what they mean, they are used, but
they works, that's fine. That's fair enough. But at
the same time, I put it that first, those
interactions uh and our ability to empathize with um
robotic agents depends on factors that are very similar
to those that shape um inter uh like intergroup
um relations between, for example, the representatives of different
um ethno racial groups. So um that many different
factors may shape our attitudes towards robots and uh
they may affect the, the way we empathize with
them or if we empathize with them or how
much, how is the level of this empathy? Uh
And the third thing was that I also a
as a philosopher, I know that many, many of
us are very conservative in a way. Um We
understand such a basic uh concept such as society.
So for example, when I start, uh when I
wrote my first uh paper about empathy in human
interactions, and I send it to some Polish journal.
Uh I get a review that it is uh
nonsense to talk about any kind of social relations
with robots because robots cannot be social agents, right?
Because social agents need to be conscious. Uh AND
they need to have some kind of social intentions,
et cetera. But yeah, but at the same time,
our social ontology is changing when, when our culture
is changing and it is shaped by technology, right?
And we are thinking about animals in terms of
personhood. So why not to think about robots as
some kind of partners in our social reality, especially
that it is more about how we interpret them
uh than if they like if robots feel empathy
because of course, at this stage of our technology,
it's, yeah, it's a very abstract question. Um My
question was more about is it um useful or
is it justified to use the term from methodological
point of view to use the term empathy while
studying interaction between people and robots. But and yes,
it is from my point of view, it is,
it is uh it is very um it there
are many arguments supporting the the thesis that that
empathy is something that that can be uh successfully
used uh in human robot interaction studies. Uh First
of all, as I already said, people report feeling
empathy, then neuro head scans and F MRI studies
show similar levels of activity in similar brain areas
that uh yeah, then like the most important thing
is that s the function of social robots is
to somehow get into social interaction with their users,
right? For example, to become a substitute of human
relations when it comes to other people in houses,
when they feel very lonely. Uh It's it's getting
more and more popular even here in my city
in Pozna uh in in some uh hospitals or
uh places where, where with many elder people and
we have those uh small um se not Sequels
but um some white like sea creature, which is
super sweet and cool. Like, like the one that
is playing in a ball in a circus, like
in a very stereotype,
stereotypical uh dolphins,
not dolphins. Um, NEVER mind. Sorry. Uh In po
it's Foer.
00, yeah. Oh my God. I, I'm missing the
name.
I'm also
missing. Uh IT'S, it's a sea, it's not sea
lion or is it?
Yeah, I don't know why.
Look, I'm also not sure, at least at the
moment, I'm not sure if it's sea lion
or not. So sorry people uh excuse us. We
are.
Yeah, I, I usually, I usually do not talk,
I usually do not talk about these animals in
this. Yeah,
me neither. So, so yeah. Uh THEY are used
in many that kind of situations where as a
substitute of, of human interactions like social interactions and
it is totally relevant because our societies are getting
older and, and we have to do something about
it right? There is more and more older people
in our communities that, that feel this loneliness and
it affects their mental and physical health. So um
yeah, why um why this is a question? Like
why bother? OK. There are those studies that use
this term empathy, people report it. So why, why
it's, it's something to, to, to talk about, right?
Even if some philosopher said it's no, it's a
nonsense because robots cannot be social. It is just
one person in Poland, right? Uh uh Yeah, but,
but I thought that maybe um again, it would
be much um more functional and much more useful
if we try to somehow recognize how this empathy
thing is understood in that kind of research. And
what does it really mean? And is it the
same empathy as we feel uh when we have
a contact with people or not, usually empathy is
understood as some kind of relation, like something that
you feel because someone else felt right is like
a coil, right? Like uh like some kind of
effect because someone else felt something there are those
um theories about mirror neurons and things like that.
It's not that important in this context, but what
is important is all right. So how can we
empathize with some something that doesn't even feel right?
Um Why, why should we research something like this?
Uh First as I said, because this is the
function of those mechanisms, they sh in some cases,
they should make us feel empathy, empathetic. But in
other cases, in other situations, we should also know
how to stop this. Um THIS uh some kind
of uh empathic relation because it might be uh
unfunctional or unuseful. For example, as in the case
of military robots, when they should just b um
some kind of like they just support human operators
and and uh human um forces on a on
the front line. But if those people who work
with those robots feel empathy towards them, then their
life may be endangered and there are some cases
of such situations, right? So we have to know,
we, first of all, we can learn a lot
about ourselves about our ability to empathize with others
by studying human robot interactions. Because it's much easier
for example, to, to repeat some kind of experiments
with robots than to repeat them with people to
somehow I don't know, to check how we uh
uh rep replay or like how we um react
to uh when we see robots being heard, then
how we react, seeing people being hurt, right? So
yeah, we can learn a lot about empathy in
people like, you know, uh by, by that kind
of research. And I think it's fascinating also, I
think it's fascinating how we understand empathy. Maybe it's
not something very like substantial, maybe there is a,
it is more uh moral relational thing. And there
are that kind of interpretations of relations between robots
and people that this is a matter of relation.
And it doesn't really matter if robot answer to
us with the real feelings, it's more a matter
of what is happening, which was between human, like
uh be between human and robotic agent. And I
think when it comes to social robots, especially the
uh to the, when it comes to those who,
who could work in health care, for example, um
the this question about this relation and how to
design this relation, how we should design the the
look of the robot, its name its uh its
voice because all of the those little details matter
when it comes to interactions with others because we
may feel more familiar with them or less familiar,
we may feel endangered or, or, or not by
someone who, who is so different than us or,
or, or too, too alike as us. So trying
to, to answer to the question is the real
empathy between in those interactions? Mm I understood that.
OK. It's there are there are there are really
more interesting questions there, like what kind of factors
shape this relation, how we can change it in
which situations it is good to somehow heighten this
level of empathy towards robots in which we should
somehow lower it and how it can change our
society as a whole. Mm If we will use
that kind of manipulations also, what kind of dangerous
comes with a manipulation uh with our empathetic reactions
to robots? We can easily imagine that some kind
of very cute puppy like robots will ask us
to for example, will be will be sold as
the toys and ask our Children to to buy
them more um more I don't know to like
toys or clothes or other kind of stuff uh
or some kind of applications. And by doing those
cute faces like from uh Pixar movies, they will
just manipulate our reactions and make us feel uh
pretty, you know, vulnerable to, to, to what they
ask for, especially if they will create relations with
the the youngest Children, for example, right. So yeah,
there, there are a lot of questions here that
are very interesting from my point of view and
and empathy is just a yeah, the question about
empathy is just a starting question here. Probably.
No, that that is all very interesting and I
guess uh just uh and this probably will be
my last question. But uh you mentioned something at
a certain point there, you mentioned uh the relational
aspect that perhaps many people question that we are
really able to establish some sort of relationship with
robots. But actually, I mean, there are people out
there that report uh experiencing a sort of relational
thing, right? With uh with robots, like for example,
social robots and now and then you hear it
also applied to sex robots, for example, so that
that's something that we also have to consider. It's
not just because robots might not be able at
least at this stage. And I'm not sure if
they ever will be able to do that, to
feel something about us to have for there to
be some sort of let's say emotional reciprocity or
something along those lines that people uh do not
sometimes think about uh or uh think about the
their robots, the robots they use or interact with
certain ways as having a relationship with them, right?
Um Yeah, like this is happening all the time
when people fall, fell in love with uh robots,
for example, or robotic dolls. Uh THOSE sexual robots,
uh There is maybe more um radical form uh
of such a situation when people suffer from something
called object ofilia and they fell in love in
objects. So for example, there's this story about women
who fell in love with Eiffel Tower, right? Or,
or things like that. Uh But when it comes
to, to social robots, uh mm The question is
how we define emotions and how we define relations
and what really matters to us, right? Can we
say that we feel sad because something happened to
Robert? Um Yes, of course, we can feel sad
in such a situation. There are examples of those
uh movies from Boston dynamics, right? When where people
kick robots that are, are very, that move in
a very biological way and have this animal like
shape. So many people report that uh feeling empathy
those to those to those creatures, creatures mechanisms. And
they even um there was even this website with
the petition stop uh robot abuse and things like
that. So yes, of course, it is similar to
our human interaction from my perspective, like I don't
know if people who I know who I trust
and who I take care for are not, for
example, psychopaths and just don't manipulate me, right? Um
I don't know if people who pretend to be
interested in my, uh, well, being really are, um,
if I go to a shop, people are nice
and they are smiling, smiling. Uh, AND I usually
reply with a smile. Right. But is it a
true relation? They are getting money for it and
maybe they are frustrating and thinking about, I don't
know, putting a knife in my back. Right. How
can I know?
Yeah, I guess, I guess that, I guess, I
guess that what you're alluding to there is the
fact that, ok, so when it comes to robots,
perhaps there's nothing there, at least on their side
psychologically, but sometimes when it comes to humans themselves,
uh there can be something there but it might
be deceitful sometimes. And so, I mean, the things
we attribute to other people uh might not correspond
to. Um,
NO, I, I wanted to say that, um, does
it really matter if robots are responding with the
same kind of like something similar um for us,
for our society at this stage, right, at the
stage of uh of uh development, technical development and
social development. Of course, we can theorize about feeling
robots in the future, but we know so little
about our own reactions and emotions and we have
so many issues with peoples and their relations the
to that having those robots and being able to
investigate some of those questions by looking at them
and maybe also to co shape and, and answer
to some of the needs of people with the
use of robots. Uh THIS is relevant and, and
how we can do it by looking at those
um at those relations. Yeah, in a relational way
understood as a, in a, in a way as
proposed by um Damiano and Da Michel, for example.
So in terms of some kind of emergent um
phenomena, we have action and reaction and, and the
direction of the robot is affecting us. And it
is a complex way of, you know, like um
some kind of uh biological uh behaviors, something new
is emerging. And this uh this, this new thing
is uh probably mo and 100% more important to
us because we are this conscious uh and intentional
uh partner of this, this interaction. And, and yeah,
and this is, this is what is crucial here
that whatever robot do and can I I'm not
gonna say feel because of course, it is a
nonsense but whatever it the robot and process maybe
uh it is not that important at this moment,
right? When, when we think about human robot interactions,
it is important when we think about robot rights
and like question like that kind of questions. But
but when we think about the development of our
society and our knowledge about ourselves and our society,
I believe that um there are concepts of empathy
and emotions that are much more interesting than just
saying robots cannot empathize, they cannot feel. So we
cannot empathize with them because this won't be a
real empathy. So you are, you are all diseased
like you are all lying to yourself. You cannot
have those feelings and if you think you have
those feelings, yeah, it is not true, right? This
is very uncreative way of, of talking about the
that that kind of problems from my perspective. It's,
it's easy to say you are lying to yourself.
It's much more interesting to say maybe there is
something here that is happening and we have to
investigate this again process, right? Um Yeah, I love
the process while thinking about relations and entities and
uh about our environment and, and I think it,
it makes um my life as a researcher mu
much more exciting than if I would just stuck
with those conservative uh and very again, very stable
and essentialist categories. Uh Because probably as you see
that um my way of thinking about using category
of race in biomedical research and empathy here is
somehow similar like how to maybe revise it, understand
it and precise it to make it more useful
and and more appropriate, maybe. Mhm For scientifical use.
No. Yeah, that, that makes for a very interesting
parallel here. Uh AND connects very well. I guess
our prior discussion about race and ethnicity with these
discussion about empathy applied to human robot interaction. So
Johan uh I think that perhaps this is a
good point to end on to wrap up our
interview on. So just before we go, would you
like to tell people where they can find you
and your work on the internet?
Oh, yeah, of course, I'm not prepared for that.
But, um, it's very easy to find me on
Twitter or Research Gate or uh other sources. I
also have my website. Uh I don't remember the
address right now. Uh However, if you look for
Yona Carolina Malinovsky on the Twitter or research guide
or uh my university uh website, there is a
link to, to, to my uh site as well.
So, yeah, if you are interested in anything I
do, you can always email me or uh yeah,
I will be very happy to answer to any
question. And thank you one more time for um
your invitation, Ricardo. And it was a huge pleasure
and a huge honor for me to be here.
Uh Sorry for being so chaotic and sorry for
my uh language problems. Uh But I hope it
was a pleasure uh somehow interesting for, for you.
Thank you for all of those who listened to
it in the end.
No, really? No. Look, it was great. I had
lots of fun talking to you. So thank you
so much for accepting the invitation. And uh if
you're open to it, please come on the show
again somewhere in the future because I bet that
we will have some other very interesting things to
talk about. And Thank you for your kind words
and thank you again for coming on the show.
Of course.
Thank you very much.
Hi guys. Thank you for watching this interview. Until
the end. If you liked it, please share it.
Leave a like and hit the subscription button. The
show is brought to you by N Lights Learning
and development. Then differently check the website at N
lights.com and also please consider supporting the show on
Patreon or paypal. I would also like to give
a huge thank you to my main patrons and
paypal supporters, Perera Larson, Jerry Muller and Frederick Suno
Bernard Seche O of Alex Adam Castle Matthew Whitting
be no wolf, Tim Ho Erica LJ Conners, Philip
Forrest Connolly. Then the Met Robert Wine in NAI
Z Mark Nevs calling Hol Brookfield, Governor Mikel Stormer
Samuel Andre Francis for Agns Ferus and H her
meal and lain. Jung Y and the K Hes
Mark Smith J Tom Hummel s friends, David Sloan
Wilson. Ya dear, Ro Ro Diego, Jan Punter, Romani
Charlotte Bli Nicole Barba, Adam Hunt, Pavlo Stassi Na
Me, Gary G Alman Sam of Zed YPJ Barboza,
Julian Price Edward Hall, Eden Broner Douglas Fry Franca,
Beto Lati W Cortez or Solis Scott Zachary FTD
and W Daniel Friedman, William Buckner, Paul Giorgio, Luke
Loki, Georgio, Theophano Chris Williams and Peter Wo David
Williams, the Ausa Anton Erickson Charles Murray, Alex Shaw,
Marie Martinez, Coralie Chevalier, Bangalore, Larry Dey junior, old
Ebon Starry, Michael Bailey. Then Spur by Robert Grassy
Zorn. Jeff mcmahon, Jake Zul Barnabas Radick, Mark Kempel,
Thomas Dvor Luke Neeson, Chris Tory Kimberley Johnson, Benjamin
Gilbert Jessica. No week. Linda Brendan Nicholas Carlson, Ismael
Bensley Man George Katis, Valentine Steinman, Perras, Kate Von
Goler, Alexander Albert Liam Dan Biar Masoud Ali Mohammadi
Perpendicular Jer Urla. Good enough, Gregory Hastings David Pins
of Sean Nelson, Mike Levin and Jos Net. A
special thanks to my producers is our web, Jim
Frank Lucani. Tom Vig and Bernard N Cortes Dixon,
Bendik Mueller Thomas Rumble, Catherine and Patrick Tobin, John
Carl Negro, Nick Ortiz and Nick Golden. And to
my executive producers, Matthew lavender, Sergi, Adrian Bogdan Knit
and Rosie. Thank you for all.